[Music]
foreign
speaking of the mainstream media it's
hard to imagine this today but there
used to be a time in this country when
people took the Washington Post
seriously they probably shouldn't have
you know they certainly shouldn't have
the country would have been better off
if they hadn't but they did and yet to
be fair this was this was long before
the post-hired theater kids to make tick
tocks before Russia gay before Taylor
Lorenz so let's go back to the dark ages
of the early 1990s when everyone got
their news from papers like the
Washington Post that's when the post ran
a deep dive into a question that the
whole country was asking at the time
here's the headline quote is Prozac
really the wonder drug for depression
the answer according to the post
rigorous reporting in that piece seemed
to be yes the science was settled
depression happens when you don't have
enough serotonin so if you give people
more serotonin uh they're happy
plus there are other benefits too The
Washington Post reported at the time
quote while other antidepressants have
been linked to weight gain Prozac has
been associated with weight loss an
advantage for some depressed people
what a breakthrough thanks to Prozac you
can stop wondering if you're sad and
obese because of your life choices you
can get rid of both problems with just
one pill it took 30 years until we
learned that from a medical perspective
um none of that was true
studies show that nearly half of
patients gain significant weight on
Prozac and it turns out that Prozac
didn't do much about depression either
which was supposed to be the point of
the drug compared to 30 years ago when
45 million Americans weren't taking
Prozac we had fewer suicides fewer mass
shootings fewer overdoses back then
why exactly didn't Prozac work as
advertised well it took until last year
which is a long time since the early
1990s until we got some kind of
explanation turns out that scientists
had no clue what Prozac was doing in the
first place one of the leading journals
in Psychiatry determined that quote the
main areas of Serotonin research provide
no consistent evidence of there being an
association between serotonin and
depression
that should have been a blockbuster
story but it was out of the news in like
less than a week
who cares if we don't know what ssris do
they tell you just shut up and take them
and give some to your kids too
that's their actual argument as of today
they lied about how it works and there's
no evidence that it does work
take it anyway
and tens of millions of Americans are
still doing just that
what explains that like why are people
still taking it with opioids there's a
clear explanation people became addicted
based on lies from drug companies and
doctors but with Prozac it's a lot less
clear why are people of their own
volition taking ssris to solve all their
problems when even the Pharma companies
admit that the ssris don't work as
advertised
these drugs have serious side effects by
the way ssris can be can cause birth
defects they can kill your sex drive
they can make you agitated and yet
people are still taking them for no
apparent benefit why
whatever the answer to that question is
maybe people are desperate maybe they're
badly misinformed by the billions of
Pharma ad dollars maybe it's something
else maybe it's a combination this is
not an issue that's going away big
pharma's grift is now expanding far
beyond ssris like Prozac consider the
current wonder drug named ozempic you've
probably heard the jingle if you haven't
I'm not going to sing it for you ozempic
began as a diabetes drug when it came to
Market a few years ago recently though
as epic has transformed in the words of
NPR into a blockbuster diet drug because
people taking it notice that they lost a
lot of weight
this February nearly 400 000 Oz epic
prescriptions were filled that's an
increase of more than a hundred percent
from the previous year
according to NPR that means those epic
has had a rise to super stardom
they say it's a hot commodity
run out and get your prescription today
if you want to lose weight
now it's worth pausing for a moment to
consider the irony of NPR which runs a
segment every day about how fat people
are healthy and beautiful now telling
you to buy some ozempic because in truth
being fat is a disease that needs to be
cured
the entire mainstream media toes this
line being fat is good
and also being fed is a disorder that
happens to you and you have no control
over it
of course both approaches are wrong fat
positivity is a cult that kills hundreds
of thousands of people many of them
probably NPR listeners and being fat is
obviously a choice not an identity
you chose to be fat by eating too much
it's not something that happens to you
like scoliosis or spina bifida
so what's really going on here you know
anytime the media Outlets spin two
contradictory narratives at the same
time it's worth looking into a little
bit further and figuring out why they're
doing it so what's the real reason
they're promoting ozempic keep in mind
that ozepik is is not some Anodyne
substance that anyone can try out for a
few months without a problem it can kill
you this is straight from those epic
website quote ozepik may cause serious
side effects including possible thyroid
tumors including cancer
spend five minutes on Reddit you'll hear
all kinds of stories from those epic
patients about some of the other
terrible side effects one user wrote
quote it made my burp smell and taste so
ungodly disgusting think straight sulfur
plus an outhouse at a NASCAR race in
summer at the end of a race weekend I'm
not exaggerating that it was complete
complete projectile vomiting out of my
nose and mouth it was an absolutely
ungodly horrible experience
Anna 2 because a podcaster told one news
outlet that she had a similar story on
ozempic quote I had no energy constant
nausea and what I call power puking
now you wouldn't think a drug that
induces power puking would be promoted
by every mediality in the country but
this one is just like Prozac every day
we're hearing about the miraculous
ozempic the Atlantic is out with a new
piece explaining that the wonder drug
doesn't just cure diabetes and obesity
it also cures credit card debt and every
other problem you can think of
did scientists accidentally invent an
anti-addiction drug the Atlantic asks
according to the piece quote people
taking those epic for weight loss say
that they have also stopped drinking
smoking shopping and even nail biting
basically it solves everything but maybe
acne when you're just starting out
you're trying to build a career one of
the big things is you got to figure out
how to stand out from the crowd but
standing out for the crowd can be tough
especially when you're looking for a job
or when you're hiring too looking to
find an application that really stands
out is a challenge that's why you need
to check out zip recruiter zip recruiter
helps you find the most qualified people
for your roles and find them fast right
now you can try a zip recruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com Walsh ziprecruiters
matching technology helps you find the
most qualified candidates for a wide
range of roles see a candidate you like
well you can easily send them a personal
invite so they're more likely to apply
their user-friendly dashboard makes it
easy to filter review and rate your
candidates all from one place that zip
recruiter help you find the best people
for all of your roles four out of five
employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
you can see for yourself how it works go
to ziprecruiter.com Walsh to try zip
recruiter for free again that's
zippercruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire you know the first step in uh
growing up and being a real man is
getting off your parents phone plan
getting your own cell phone plan gives
you a sense of Independence and
responsibility it's a step towards
becoming more self-sufficient by paying
for your own finances you learn how to
budget and manage your money there are a
ton of cell phone providers out there
unfortunately most of them want to lock
you into these contracts then tack on
hidden fees at any chance they get
that's why I'm a big fan of pure talk
there are no contracts no hassles you
can cancel at any time it's very simple
Pure Talk is also giving you a free 5G
Samsung Galaxy phone
when you sign up for the 55 per month
unlimited plan plus hot spot today they
use the same Nationwide networks as
major carries so you get all the same
coverage that you do but a lot cheaper a
lot easier switching over to Pure Talk
is so easy you can make the switch keep
your cell phone keep your phone number
with their Us customer service team you
can make the switch in as little as 10
minutes Pure Talk is so sure you're
going to love your service that they're
backing it up with a 100 money back
guarantee so go to puretalk.com enter
promo code Walsh just say 50 off your
first month that's puretalk.com promo
code walls Pure Talk is simply smarter
Wireless
here's how the Atlantic article begins
all her life Victoria Rutledge thought
of herself as somebody with an addictive
personality her first addiction was
alcohol after she got sober in her early
30s she replaced drinking with food and
shopping which she thought about
constantly she would spend 500 on
organic groceries only to have them go
bad in her fridge I couldn't stop from
going to that extreme she told me when
she ran errands at Target she would
impulsively throw extra things candles
makeup skin care products into her cart
then this woman started taking a version
of ozempic and suddenly according to
Atlantic all her problems went away
quote her food thoughts quieted down she
lost weight but most surprisingly she
walked out of Target one day and
realized her cart contained only the
four things she came to buy
another woman Mary Marr reported similar
results Mar said that she hopes to stay
on those epic forever quote it's
incredibly validating she told the
Atlantic it's incredibly validating
medicine meant to affirm and validate
you know there's a lot of that going
around these days
now to be clear there's there's no
scientific basis that explains what if
anything is happening here ozepik
releases a hormone that tricks the
pancreas into releasing more insulin
which sends signals to the brain that we
don't fully understand the Atlantic
admits that quote the exact mechanism
and weight of weight loss is still
unclear
most intriguing it also seems to reach
and act directly on the brain
now the peace quotes of biologist saying
that those epic pseudo-hormones quote
appear to actually bind to receptors on
neurons in several parts of the brain
so just like Prozac it's supposed to
solve a bunch of problems all at once
but no one's really sure how
before ozampic Mary Mar and Victoria
Rutledge just couldn't resist putting
unnecessary garbage in their shopping
cart at Target now they no longer have
those inclinations those thoughts those
thoughts
their thought process has been changed
by a drug and nobody seems interested in
asking any questions about that
like how does that happen
what are the long-term effects of people
flooding their bodies with ozempic for
80 years
what other effects is this having on
these users personality or day-to-day
interactions with other people
no one has any idea there haven't been
any long-term studies on this just like
there were no long-term studies on
Prozac or cross-sex hormones for
children
ozepik might make people's lives worse
in many ways as Prozac did we don't know
all we know is that people who are
desperate for validation for assurances
that they're not responsible for their
own actions which is what they want
validated are welcome to load up on
ozempic
take the pill it'll make you feel better
don't think about it
that's the pitch from Big Pharma
now let's think about the implications
of this for a moment assume that ozempic
works just as the Atlantic is describing
if this drug stops people from shopping
too much
then it has somehow mitigated the desire
to shop
but that desire is a conscious thing in
the mind which means that the drug is in
a literal sense manipulating people's
thoughts
and of course this is nothing new all
psychiatric drugs do this
but the Mind itself is still in many
ways a mystery to science like the
doctors that are prescribing things that
affect your mind they can't even tell
you what exactly the mind is or where it
comes from or how it works
which means the doctors who prescribe
this stuff don't know exactly how the
drugs work or what it means and they
can't grasp the full implications
or treating people like machines
incapable of changing their own behavior
or engaging in self-control and that's
exactly how the system wants you to see
yourself
you cannot fix this problem yourself
you know if you're Victoria Rutledge
somehow it was it was Victoria Rutledge
incapable of going to Target and only
buying a couple things like she couldn't
physically impossible
or did it just require a little bit of
effort and self-control that she didn't
feel like
generating
think about every drug and there are
many of them
that weren't about Suicidal Thoughts as
a side effect ironically Prozac which is
supposed to cure depression has been
known to drive people to Suicide instead
this means that a drug is a drug here's
what it means that a drug is putting
self-destructive thoughts into a
person's mind
suicidal people are Not Mere animals
acting on Insta Instinct they are again
our conscious agents responding to
thought processes
these drugs are in some way causing
these thought processes
how does that work how can a pill make a
person want to kill themselves
how can a pill put in a person's mind
the thought you should kill yourself
nobody really knows
yeah they churn out the pills and the
prescriptions anyway
you know in ancient times before
medicine was more about marketing than
Healthcare Physicians knew uh to stay
away from false panaceas like this uh
one expression was leave your drugs in
the chemist's pot if you can heal the
patient with food
well that's ancient wisdom it's gone now
now we heal patients food problems with
drugs from the chemist pot
and we heal their shopping problems and
their drinking problems too
30 years from now we might learn what
we're actually doing to these people
but for now ozempic is canceled
and I'll do it for this part of the show
as we move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed